every age I turn I think about how old
of a child my mom had when she was my
age at 21 she had a one-year-old at 25 a
five-year-old I try to imagine what my
life would be like now with a child I've
got glimpses of it carting around
children and the snow through Brooklyn
when I was a nanny the brand of mom I
nanny for differed greatly from my own
mother these moms were all over 40 in
fact most were over 50 and they had
houses and plans and firm rules these
ladies bought organic produce they were
nice don't get me wrong but my mom and I
had more fun when I was little I would
sit in the front seat of the car and we
would belt Alanis Forsett caps for sale
was craps for sale every time I
convinced her to read it that way to me
a bedtime and I wouldn't be able to stop
laughing when other 20-somethings were
bumbling in bars until closing time and
washing hookups down with cold pizza my
mom was busy being a mom in time though
I did turn into a teenager who could
wipe their own snot and make their own
meals moms and teenage daughters
notoriously sparked misunderstandings in
melodrama and we weren't any different
in arguments I would glare at her and
hatefully spit the words you're supposed
to be a mom I was adamant that moms
didn't litter the kitchen table with
bottles and mixers that they didn't date
21 year olds and that they didn't
attempt sylvia plath antics involving
ovens I've always hated Sylvia Plath
sense and have refused to read any word
she wrote I forgot that before being a
mom she was a person a person on their
own journey a person who experiences
sadness and needs help - a person whose
identity is not just mom but also woman
an artist and lover sometimes I think
about my mother like she's a person who
isn't related to me
I marvel at how brave and strong this
woman is to have raised me without the
support of her family this woman who put
herself through college by working at
minimum wage jobs while still taking
care of me and I can only feel grateful
grateful that I have a mom who is not
just a mom but is also a friend
you